and the British government said slow
your roll there Louis we are not sending
a young 26 year old blonde woman to
Tanzania to study apes without an escort
and by escort they of course meant a man
right they didn't want her to go without
a man to protect her and she said okay
great I'll take an escort she took her
mother van so this is van Goodall up on
her left on the beach at Gombe and then
in her tent and so van and Jean is who
set up the study of chimpanzees at Gombe
for the first two years so Jane was
walking into a place where the
chimpanzees were very scared of humans
they had been hunted they were not
comfortable with her being in their
presence so she did a very kind of at
the time thought to be kind of a crazy
things she just went to this place
called Jane's Peak and every day she sat
in the same clothes with the same
equipment and was very just still and
watched them across the valley and
stayed very consistent very predictable
until the chimps kind of lost their fear
from far away and then she subsequently
over many years was able to get them to
lose their fear from very close up Jane
you know much like her mentor Louis
there were kind of two things about her
she was very bold and brave and kind of
wanted to do things her own way she also
didn't have any formal college education
she had only gone to secretary or school
so she decided like oh the best way to
get to understand these animals is to
study them as individuals
I'd like to learn who they are I'd like
to know their personalities I'd like to
learn about who their friends are their
emotions and she did crazy things like
giving them names instead of using
numbers to identify them and the
scientific establishment of the time was
like that's really cute sweetie but like
that's not the way we do things
and now here we are 60 years later in
the Gumby study is still going strong as
I'm evidence of standing in front of you
so what Jane really changed in the in
the field of studying animal behavior
was making it okay eventually to think
about these animals in terms of being
individuals with individual personal
relationships friendships personalities
ammo
Shen's and really conducting close
observation of individuals and their
individual stories that's what was
really different about Jane's study with
the chimps now Jane was one of these try
mates as I mentioned before and what's
really interesting about these three is
they really did operate kind of like
siblings so this is kind of a story of
to dig dig to find out but Jane was very
much the older sibling like the
responsible you know one Diane has been
reported to be the kind of the the
jealous middle sibling and brute a was
like the happy baby who's just happy to
be there with everybody and so that Lois
kind of set up this system where after
Jane's study became a success and he met
Diane and Diane very similar to Jane
walked up to him and said I want to do
what she did but with a different animal
he had this proving ground for Diane and
then Baruti and what he did was he would
first send them to Van Goodall in London
they would have to stay with van for
several weeks until she determined that
they were okay and then he would send
them to Jane and Gombe so she could
field test them and make sure they were
okay now nobody knows never revealed
what these metrics were so we don't know
but at any rate Diane passed the test
and ended up as I'll cover later at Kara
Sookie what's interesting about Diana's
is like Jane she always had more of an
affinity for animals growing up then the
normal girl she actually got along with
animals quite much more than she did
with people she had a difficult
childhood and she was desperate to be a
veterinarian but she was really bad at
chemistry and physics so instead she
became an occupational therapist with
children so he was actually fully
fledged in her career when she saw Louis
Leakey give a talk and walked up to him
afterwards and said that's what I want
to do and so in 1967 Jane started Gambia
in 1960 Diane went out in 1967 to Rwanda
and started the karisoke a Research
Center and the long-term study of
mountain gorillas there she did take a
page out of Jane's book
and really think about studying these
animals as individuals with individual
stories and histories and and aspects to
them
she habituated the animals to her
presence much less like Jane did and she
did end up forging a very close
relationship with a particular animal at
a particular gorilla named digit and
that's digit they're looking at her
field notes with her digit you know they
really really accepted Diane into their
into their community they're the
gorillas and so she forges very strong
bond with digit she has written about
this as he was like her true best friend
and he really greased the wheels with
the other gorillas like he accepted her
and the other girl is really good okay
she must be alright so digit really
paved her way here and this was a
friendship that would last all of digits
life this picture was taken ten years
later digits a fully grown adult gorilla
who would seem to be quite terrifying to
sit next to but they were they were very
close friends until his death now his
death is what changed Diane's life
forever so Diane in the morning in 1977
got a report that poachers were in her
area in Rwanda she went out to check her
groups and she found digit with his head
in his hands removed so she went in a
full 180 at that point from behavioral
research and went 100% into anti
poaching and protection of the gorillas
in her area and her methods for doing
this were quite unorthodox they were
outside of what we would envision as any
you know kind of standardized
conservation practices that we would do
today
she really chased she basically chase
after the poachers with like a knife and
chase them off and so her her her
anti-poaching efforts brought a lot of
anger to the poaching community and in
1985 she was killed in her research camp
in a crime that has never been solved so
she is buried next to her best friend
digit you can actually visit her grave
site in Rwanda so Diane's personal story
is over but there is a legacy of both
these women that I just want to touch on
before I launch into what I specifically
work on Jane is very much with us she's
very much alive and well she has more
energy than all of us in this room her
legacy is very strong this picture in
the middle is taken of a group of either
current or former researchers at Gombe
taken about two years ago Jane let me
see if I can work this thing Jane's here
in the middle I'm over here so this was
taken about two years ago and then
around you you see where we put a lot of
focus in the last couple decades is
bringing into the formal research
training our Tanzanian counterparts in
Tanzania and there's several of our
Tanzanian PhDs and and veterans a
veterinary medicine they're the Dian
Fossey
legacy despite her passing many years
ago now is also quite strong an
incredible presence in Rwanda working
very cooperatively with the government
in terms of both behavioral research and
anti poaching and Diane's legacy of
especially involving women in field
research is clear there as you look at
the pictures around the around the edges
[Music]
you
[Music]